the family of haitian president
chauvinal muiz
will not be able to hold an open casket
funeral
assassins shot him several times in the
head in front of his wife and daughter
early on wednesday later that night
police arrested these two men in the
pationville neighborhood
of porto haas they killed four other
suspects
three officers were briefly held hostage
during the raid
moyes is killing upset local residents
imagine we live in this area close to
the president even when we have problems
with the president we can't imagine they
will kill him like this
i heard something go boom like an
earthquake i thought something under the
soil had been turning
the interim prime minister urged
haitians to remain calm
i have already spoken about the state of
the siege declared the president's body
has already been transported
into the mug in the capital the first
lady is out of danger and is being
treated in florida
as per the latest information her state
is stable
moyes's death came as he was in the
middle of a political crisis
parliament had been suspended for the
past two years
and opponents accused moyes of trying to
undermine the constitution
the u.s backed moyes's decision to stay
in power for
one more year just so long as elections
took place on time
you need a lot more information but it
is
very worrisome about the state even as
the investigation begins
interim prime minister khloe joseph and
the man muys had picked to succeed him
are fighting over who's in charge
moyes's widow martine was flown to the
u.s to recover from her injuries
but haiti's border with the dominican
republic is now closed
authorities have shut down the airport
until further notice
raising questions about how haiti will
recover
from this attack on the body politic
rosalyn jordan al jazeera washington